Peter Brown you reviewed a video game
four games baha i do that from time to
time I hear this is like a really it's
like a screen so it's like an
interactive screen saver it's about five
minutes long yeah my thirty bucks no
okay well does cost thirty dollars yeah
here's solid ground zeroes yeah the
prologue to the phantom pain which is
coming out in a couple of years probably
one stage yeah and this is a game which
has come under some sort of controversy
because people think that you could
complete it quickly but from your review
it sounds like that's not really the way
this game is supposed to be I think it
depends well you can there's no way that
you're supposed to play it right if you
go into it just for the story you may
finish it in less than two hours I mean
I was able to do that but at the same
time when you finish the main mission
you unlock other missions and there's
just so much to do and see in the game
that that's really where the meat of it
is and that's what I really enjoyed
about it the story was good but once
that ended that's when I really felt
like the game opened up to me and but
you know not everyone look plays games
the way I do well I want to see we play
a game right now yeah and I'm gonna
challenge myself to collect all of the
nine hidden items oh my god a suit well
she will see yes it is for the folks at
home we're not gonna dive into the story
parts of this game and for fear of that
yeah I'm gonna skip this well really
there's only 2 cutscenes so unless I
finish it which I won't do be drawn to
cut scenes takes about two hours sounds
like Hideo Kojima yeah the game is only
about 10 seconds yeah thank you alright
David Hayter of course not voicing snake
this time around it is keeping
supplement yes not like I think he does
a really great job I mean Metal Gear has
typically had very interesting cut
scenes with really over-the-top dialogue
and action and everything yeah and no
pun intended here but this is more
grounded in reality if you all I know I
see what I was good I liked it the yeah
Kiefer Sutherland gives a much more
natural delivery and I think it really
does the game's service cuz overall it's
a much more serious game I'm gonna skip
this intro goes I know I've seen a
thousand times and I also think it's a
cut seeing the ocean they really stood a
year ago yeah it's so first of all this
game looks pretty great like the water
effects I'm super into
alright so I was gonna try to collect
all the badges but I seem to have
collected all of them so what I'm gonna
do is I just gonna go in that's how good
you are you are coming in hot there's a
Michael Bay action happening range Danny
when you say you like the water you mean
your moisture glistening off of snakes
taut buttocks that is exactly what I'm
getting at I just wanted to put in the
subtext for you viewers at home Danny
they don't know what my desktop
background is yeah so like yeah I get
context so in terms of the action here
is this very much in the the sort of
form of mileage lot of 4 is just its own
thing middle your solid four depending
on which part of the game you're
referring to you know like the start of
that game there's a lot of action going
on around here in the middle of a war
here you're infiltrating a black site
you know a military base that's sort of
a you know unofficial no one's really
acknowledging it and you know it's it's
a much less action-oriented game unless
you want to make it that one you know
make it sort of an explosive experience
because there's all sorts of stuff you
can still vehicles you can get a grenade
launcher you can you know shoot
explosive barrels or if you play like me
when you silly I like to play you can
sneak around and shoot guys in the head
and we can go to sleep and they'll never
notice you is that the slow mo not yet
one almost I hope this know what happens
this T is so far away i'd go to sleep
bad working a blue laser gun that's a
gay usually means he's asleep what i
like about the slow mo is that in at
least in the playstation 4 version you
can see like individual raindrops like
slowing down in front of the screen a
little hops it I've seen the slow mo
happen as well we'll have to eat you'll
have to show them at some point oh yeah
the demos of course yeah it's called
reflex mode and yeah I basically gives
you a last second chance to get out of
harm's way and you said you can turn
that on a lot of the other options off
if you want to play like super hardcore
mode yes up here we go all right look at
those right I have like just a couple
seconds she at this guy murder dr.
waters making his net yeah it does make
the game a little bit easy when that
happened but it doesn't always happen
when you when you expect it okay
sometimes when you have multiple enemies
around you that you don't see and that
happens it's very easy to have four
people spot you at one so you can maybe
only take out one at a time yeah and
that really just leaves you exposed and
you get shot sometimes a diet that's not
cool and this may be a really weird
reference but when I was sitting down
watching you play this game for the past
week I got like a real project IGI feel
for this word project I'm going in I'm
going he's so good it was one of those
games where you had to infiltrate
different bases but it was always fun to
like try it one way and then we load
that same level and then played a
different didn't work [ __ ] what are you
throwing at him Acker was trying to
distract him with a cartridge oh that's
definitely gonna distract him oh you
just distracted him right oh all right
I'm just gonna blow this barrel up to
because I'll motion viral Oh boom that's
pretty typical pretty kooky would use
all of these different records that are
popping up far this distance sent enemy
flying 4.6 meters yeah it tracks I mean
it'll track how long you spend crop you
know crouched versus you know upright
can you drive that cherry that that
cherry picker thing or whatever it was
forklifts can you drive that nobody
drive the forklift I've never taken that
before you can't and don't think so all
right where's game over look I know just
not as good as Shenmue yeah it's on
blocks man it's not going I have a
general rulers if you have a forklift in
a game you have to be able to drive it
if not don't put the forklift in the
game it was just like like the world's
biggest tease I did some of that in GTA
5 yeah just draw it drive up to someone
on the freeway to start looking for cars
yeah they like it lifting up animals if
you have any questions for Peter about
Metal Gear Solid 5 grams zeroes feel
free to put them in the twitch job or
the games more comments and I will relay
them to you and this video game is not a
full price video game thats true correct
that is here you can pay thirty dollars
for a physical or digital next-gen
version thirty dollars for the physical
physical current-gen or twenty dollars
to download it on ps3 and 360 the choice
is it
oh my god or you can not buy where you
can not buy it it also an option you can
spend that money on whatever you want
buy some food don't need to charity my
other game go to a roller coaster yeah
well yeah you can do that and that might
were not in the thirty dollar yeah but
[ __ ] ostermore Eminem straight sorry you
know Eminem strangers asked in a twitch
chat and how does it compare to the mega
sada to tanker plans in terms of like
the level format or like have this game
approaches it like that sort of right
you know individual section is it work
well I mean I know a lot of people spend
a lot of time in the tanker because it's
sort of filled with all these very uh
you know different environments even
though they're compact right a lot of
opportunities to play the game in
different ways that's very similar here
and and that's the reason I you know I
beat the story I'm gonna die early same
can you go in that vehicle yes I want to
protect myself first you can protect the
getting into it shut up um I speak ya
know I think like the tanker you can
spend a lot of time in here to sort of
playing around and you know it's not
it's not for everyone like I'm not gonna
say that like there's any one way to
play this game but I know that I just
like to turn it on and dick around as it
were yeah and you're certainly doing
that there oh yeah take out that guard
tower that is some michael bay you're
not yeah do you think there's a
significance at difference in terms of
visuals between this in the playstation
or the xbox 360 version ok so you ain't
us on ps4 join us on ps4 the resolution
makes it definitely makes a difference
when you're trying to head shot people
so this is bringing in 1080 1080
everything else is 720 but the xbox one
and ps4 versions were both at 60 frames
per second that said current gen ps3 and
360 are 7 20 to 30 yeah but I spent a
lot of time playing the 360 version and
I really didn't mind it ok first it was
jarring especially during the intercut
soon because there's a lot of shaky cam
going rush and that's true the main game
but you can also turn shaky cam off if
the discrepancy is you know presented by
the framerate bother you you said at one
point though it was harder for you to
hit like a nice jaw not as unfortunate
oh that won't be sent flying that was
also is I'm not sure if this I think its
a spoiler on Austin don't answer the
question I know
wait there is a character in this game
who is interesting but there is an
inviting character I don't want to spoil
okay let's not talk about them I don't
know is it the cactus Avenger who gets
mad about all the cacti your murderous I
was a cactus bummer man you said when
you're playing a couple of days ago that
you did find it easier to get headshots
on the D effort on the ps4 version yeah
but you know that really only applies
when you're at a great distance away you
know when you need to do a head shot I i
was able to do it just fine what if you
need to shoot a guy in the butt while
he's climbing or do I need to blow up
that Watchtower while he's climbing it
not there's a rule and unusual oh no
he's just starting to slowly descend
he's like oh no oh yeah there's a new
record congratulations that's pretty
good at monkey night 67 on twitch has
asked is there a box to hide in is there
a varnish okay I found no box that said
you're gonna have to play this game for
you know over a dozen hours I found
things I didn't see any hours before
that so there could be a box but I
haven't seen again what's in the bar
probably a box I have hideo kojima is
not one for fanservice guys there's no
way does it there is there are there are
plenty of little things hidden in this
game that will surprise you if as
serious as it is compared to pass
another good names it still retains I
sort of light-hearted okay i think is a
little bit of an edge there no reading
material you might find inside of a
barracks no there's none of that act
kara bare in Twitter as Peters making
this game look easy is it are you good
at metal gear solid or is this a easy or
not difficult I don't think it's games
like a week straight ok so in France you
were like unloading clips into it into
two guys they're reloading like in the
middle of nowhere is it is it is it
challenging you like it to you against a
base full of dude so yeah the when I
first started playing this game i'd i'd
probably three or four times before i
was able to make any progress into the
base snake can jump by the way jump like
well you can't you can't wait it yeah
well that was falling okay oh no oh no I
like this about like it's almost like
you're dissolving up old foe
grab for something we're playing home oh
you found an ax me down let me down
naked snick snick I'm gonna play I'm
gonna do just a little bit more how much
time I got sure we can flavor in a
couple of minutes man it's pretty good
video game I came into it I would call
it great at digital name is what
happened to the poor watermelon oh that
was for a million you're rising mmm yeah
I name this game yeah come on yes
Cynthia's one is all about cactus murder
not watermelon mutilation weight
difference uh what did you rate this
game on gamespot com I gave it an eight
cuz i think it's great it's great you'll
murder that guy are you gonna use him as
a hostage while you're in a tower i
don't think that's gonna work can you
shine the spotlight can you take off his
clothes hardly reskin are their lockers
kinda Craig County where skin he got up
can you ask him about his family are
their lockers with pictures of
half-naked woot ladies in them not that
I've found Danny I already asked the
smugglers I sorry come on do not thank
you out what did you have to plug into
your controller into a different port no
let me get the rock so you're playing
this uh you know you're kind of treating
this says just like a sandbox right now
you're no absolutely a particular goal
in mind so I had a goal in mind but I
screwed up looking pretty important i
said if i'm just so like what are what
are some of the different type of
mission objectives you might get up to
in your replaying of ground zeroes yeah
well i mean your mission objectives
don't necessarily change but I mean so
there are a lot of side missions that do
offer different challenges right so the
main one you have to evacuate people
that you know that are being held
captive on base okay Commission's after
that they range from you know a sash
this assassination
you know there's one where you're in a
helicopter and you have to protect a
covert agent in the base was trying to
escape and you're armed with a grenade
launcher and a rifle there's another one
where you have to contact an agent who
is expecting someone but you're not on
his side's we get the information out of
him and then you have to dispatch him
after the fabric after he helped you so
kindly Wars cook cruel amount yeah or
what's really interesting is that you
get most of the main story bits from the
main mission but the side ones some of
the dialogue that the characters deliver
they have like hints of maybe things to
come okay is this one of these games
worried you've got more questions about
metal gear solid job and yeah it does
afterwards yeah I mean it was a prologue
so obviously it sets up a lot of you
know stuff that's gonna come in the
future but it does also doesn't at least
hold on booth nice working thank you
right I love that what a move it fierce
face plant yeah when you hit when you
die you just like hit the ground before
you go Peter ass I'm gonna ask you so
this is obviously the prologue for
phantom pain yes is coming as you know
in the distant future perhaps there and
kazuma said this the full game will be
something like 100 times bigger than
then this how do you feel about what
that game might be and in terms of scale
is this does that mean this game is a
small game or is that just a really big
ask that cuz you were saying 100 times
bigger I think it's it's possible that
he can make a game that's geographically
that large but you know one thing I
learned about this base is that you know
there's so many things to do like I said
it's so dense with content that I'd be
really impressed if they could put a
hundred of those that are different
enough in a game and ship it you know
before the PlayStation 5 came out I
think you're going to see that it's
probably a mix of those two things it's
a really large area because it will be
open world this is more an open format
level and I think you will find a lot of
bases like this but you'll also have
your own base to manage you'll be able
to recruit soldiers and obviously the
story will be a much more important
aspect of the game at large so I think
this is a small game and it's almost
like a it's like it's like a testing lab
if you will for the new style of metal
gear cool peter brian thank you very
much coming on the show oh it's not your
solid ground zeroes
8.01 gamespot com you can go check out
the review on the site